When it comes to Marvel movies, there's a
tradition that what happens after the credits
roll can almost be as important as everything
that happens before.
Spider-Man: Homecoming is no different, as
one of its two post-credits scenes hint at
big things to come.
The other one?
Not so much...but it's still worth watching.
Let's get into some of the spoilers and explain
the post-credits scenes in Spider-Man: Homecoming.
Meet Mac Gargan
In the first and most significant post-credits
scene, the audience catches up with the defeated
Vulture, Adrian Toomes, walking through the
halls of prison after his showdown with Spider-Man.
There, he's approached by a scarred prisoner,
a criminal who was also on the Staten Island
Ferry as part of the Vulture's botched weapons
deal.
That guy's Mac Gargan, and we get a good glimpse
at the scorpion tattoo on his neck.
Ladies and gentlemen, this is the Scorpion,
one of Spider-Man's oldest bad guys.
Honor among thieves
Gargan asks Toomes about the rumor that he
knows Spider-Man's true identity.
But the former Vulture denies everything,
paying Peter back for saving both his daughter's
life, and his own.
Meanwhile, we know Gargan's got revenge on
his mind for the damage he took during the
Ferry fight.
Setting up the Sinister Six
Gargan tells Toomes that he's got lots of
friends on the outside looking to go after
Spider-Man, which seems to be a big hint that
Spidey's bad guys will soon team up.
In the comics, they're known as the Sinister
Six, a group of villains with a rotating membership
over the years.
With the Shocker still on the loose by the
end of Homecoming, it seems likely that we
already know at least two of the potential
members who will make up this evil gang of
jerks.
Seeing the Sinister Six in a Spidey sequel
wouldn't be too big of a surprise.
It's well known that Sony intended to make
a spinoff Sinister Six movie following what
they'd hoped would be the success of The Amazing
Spider-Man 2.
When that film underperformed, plans for the
movie were shelved.
That's when Sony worked out a deal with Marvel
to produce the 2017 reboot.
Now that Spidey's back in action with Sony
and Marvel hugging it out, it wouldn't be
that shocking if the pre-production work that
was done on the Sinister Six film came out
of the drawer.
Oh, that Captain America thing
Viewers who stayed to the very end of the
credits were treated to one more scene — this
one featuring Captain America himself.
Standing against a white backdrop, Cap reminds
the audience of the virtue of patience...which
is a nice way of making fun of the fans who
stayed in the theater after the interminable
credits crawl.
The joke hearkens back to the king of all
post-credits scenes: the one from Ferris Bueller's
Day Off.
"You're still here?
It's over.
Go home."
Does it have any relevance to the further
Marvel mythos?
Well, no.
It might be the most pointless post-credits
scene in MCU history, considering that even
Guardians of the Galaxy's Howard the Duck
cameo technically featured the reintroduction
of the classic character.
"Why do you let it lick you?"
"Gross."
Anybody else feel like these post-credits
scenes might be a little overhyped at this
point?
"It's over.
Go home."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too.